alright let's talk about the ant-man
trailer all right you know I had to
start out this video like this I mean it
really had to all right there we go yeah
ant-man trailer right so the trailer the
first trailer for ant-man is coming out
it's like all new Marvel moving to
Marvel Marvel Cinematic Universe I was
watching and I watched it and I was like
all right man it's coming out it's what
I know now it's kind of what I already
knew maybe this was a serviceable
trailer for sure but it wasn't like
mind-blowing [ __ ] just Michael Douglas
talking to Paul Ryan here's I hate Paul
Rudd I need you to be the new ant-man
because Michael Douglas is like Hank Pym
is like the original ant-man Paul Rudd's
like ant-man
2.0 I suppose an ant-man fan for someone
like me I mean I'll be honest with you
this is my history for ant-man this is
what I know about ant-man ant-man turns
small and ant-man is the guy in Marvel
heroes I donate all of my [ __ ] to got a
level your crafter MMO 101 man other
than that this trailer shows people with
guns and a dude in a certain ant-man
turned small that [ __ ] was cool that man
turned small looks like he's actually
small I think is the depth of field
effect where it looks like you're
looking at a dude through a magnifying
glass and like things behind him are
really blurry just makes him the effect
makes him look small he's writing a wasp
and shilling he's flying around like as
Falkor no don't reminded me others
reminded me of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles I'm gonna take you back for a
second it reminded me of this [ __ ] in
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles but really
I'm taking this trailer on faith that it
is Marvel Studios I'm part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's why this is
neat to me I'm pretty by the numbers
trailer to do talking to dude I need you
to be a hero cool and hurry you know
you're a hero I guess it didn't blow me
away because this trailer comparatively
speaking is six months before the movie
comes out and we look at the age of
Ultron trailer that came out six months
before age of Ultron comes out that
trailer holy [ __ ] trailers ready yet
Ultron owning that trailer James
Spader's all like red Reddington
maybe it's because you already knew the
characters which is why I'm like if
you're an ant-man fan this trailer might
just blow your mind
[ __ ] you even look at the Star Wars
trailer came out of here before Star
Wars is coming out that trailer gave us
a lot of [ __ ] to talk about granted it's
almost cheating because it's Star Wars
was like hey show the Millennium Falcon
have fun friends talk about back we were
going to let's crash the internet today
the coolest
man movie thing I've seen to date is
actually not part of the trailer is what
was it a tech demo it was that comic-con
and it was when he's running down the
hallway and he turns small and runs up
the dudes gun and grabs his tie and
flips him around turns big again it was
cool [ __ ] I would have liked to have
seen stuff like that in here shown him
do more than just you know ride a wasp
so ultimately this ant-man teaser
trailer made me go alright an ant-man
movies coming out cool and he turns
small and he rides a wasp but like the
old Ninja Turtle toys and then and I
like the fact that original ant-man he's
in it but he's old he's Michael
Douglas's like I need to pass the torch
that opens up a lot of story base
elements for them to villain well maybe
there's a villain from back then he's
coming around full circle oh my god but
ultimately I saw nothing mind-blowing
the crazy awesome in this trailer that
made me go oh my god this is the movie
listen [ __ ] Ultron screw that [ __ ] this
is however when there's a new superhero
movie coming up that I know nothing
about I treat it like Iron Man 1 I'm
going into it going all I can do is
surprise me at this point I might walk
out of this movie going that was one of
the coolest movies of the year and again
I might walk out of this movie going
well it finally happened Marvel Studios
is dead who knows I go into this with an
open mind I want to hear what you have
to say about it so Ant Man fans Marvel
fans Marvel haters people of all sorts
have you seen the ant-man teaser trailer
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you